if I want something I go into the future
in my brain which is powerful and I
visualize exactly what I want I have
found that every time I failed I move
closer to the goal don't discount
yourself I didn't do what I'm doing now
for 14 years because I didn't believe
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
every single day we'll be running it out
I still love you and I believe life ball
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get motivated to
change your life today
okay let's kick it off with real number
one have a vision with Damon - if I want
something I go into the future in my
brain which is powerful and I visualize
exactly what I want so I'm there I'm in
my future and then I think about every
single thing I need to do to make that
happen and every single thing that could
stop that from happening and what I need
to avoid then I go right back you
understand what I'm saying and like I
was just in the future thinking about
watching myself on my television network
so because I do that that means I have
to think what would be the worst-case
scenario and then I have to think what
would be the best-case scenario and then
I eliminate every single thing that I
think could happen which I call art
detecting and then I put everything and
every single attitude and person around
me in my vision that's gonna make me get
to what I want and also I try to get the
people around me to think about the same
exact vision so you wouldn't inspire
people and all that energy is focused on
one thing that they could visualize in
their head then it becomes a tangible
reality and I know that to be a fact
because it's happened it's a fact for me
so I continue to do that I know that
anything I can imagine I can make happen
so I am really careful about how small
my thoughts are because I don't feel
like wasting time and a 24 hour day
making this much and I could spend the
same amount of time with the same amount
of energy if I art detective right at
this much and with this much I can help
so many more people that I love rule
number two don't discount yourself with
Les Brown and one of the things that say
to people don't discount yourself I
didn't do what I'm doing now for 14
years because I didn't believe being
labeled educable mentally [ __ ]
failing in the fifth grade foot back to
the fourth grade
and no college education that I can
compete with people with PhDs and MBAs
and so for 14 years a lot of people say
they have no regrets the biggest regret
that I have that I disapproved of myself
for 14 years and then there's a
coincidence is God's way of staying
anonymous I went to a training and a guy
was speaking hmm
and Mike Williams had already said hey
brownie you know why you go see Zig
Ziglar and dr. Robert Schuller and dr.
norman vincent peale who wrote the power
of positive thinking I said because I
like the message he said no he said
you'd like to help people that's in you
you always holding court here at the
radio station
man you got a funny laugh man he said
yes and so he just kept saying that to
me and and I was out of the meet at an
event and a guy was speaking and it just
stuff like a spell came over him he said
there's somebody here who should be
doing this he said I do it because I
make a lot of money and he said I'd love
to make money he said but you you want
to change lives and you can make money
too young man young lady and he said you
know who you are
and then he paused again and he said the
reason I'm standing up here holding this
microphone and you has seated out there
I represent the thoughts you have
rejected for yourself that hit me right
between the eyes and I began to cry at
that time this is in 1980 I went outside
I called Mike Williams the telephone
call was a dime and I said Mike he said
yes I said I'm not rejecting myself
anymore do you hear me he's a brownie
calm down listen to me man I'm not
rejecting myself anymore rule number
three find your motivation with David
Goggins for several years I gave myself
a way out when you were three pounds and
I was all that I was 24 years old I
would climb a mountain I fall back down
I start climbing I fall back down for
the first 24 years of my life I went to
my first
week my second hell week and then my
third hell week came and still training
and the CEO captain Bowen looked at me
I'm on crutches I'm all jacked up he
says hey this is your last time you're
gonna go through buds zip
I had several stress fractures I had
doubled him on you I was jacked up and
he gave me a few months to heal he said
this year last time going through I
shouldn't even let you go back through
well I started making these little
training with stress fractures stress
fractures splints I'm trying to finish
just fractures starting the hardest
training argument in the world stress
fractures and this is when I started to
not put a cap on the body if the mind is
there every morning I wake up at 3:30
morning 4 o'clock in the morning go to
my dive cage go in there before anybody
saw me I get duct tape another tape from
my fore foot all the way up to the
minute my calf and I'll put two black
socks on and so I ran not using the
pivot oh my gosh
now I ran my hip flexors so for the
first 45 minutes to an hour I was an
absolutely excruciating pain but what
motivated me I'll do that whole process
was the fact that this kid came from
that I'm in the hardest training the
world in the worst shape of my entire
life
what if I can graduate amongst these
studs Wow all these guys around me are
stunts
the Stallions the gladiators in my class
they're all healthy most of them they're
not broken like this let me have some
you know Eric everybody's sick going to
the trainer but if I graduate it would
change everything for me if I can start
the hardest train in the world broken he
graduated so my mind fed off of that you
are now from the weakest man you another
hardest man to ever live if you can do
this
life is one big mind game yeah and
you're playing it with yourself is it
true I don't care it got me through the
hardest training starting out broken mm
where most people quit I had just
started Wow
and when you take that mindset and you
learn to flip that around that's what
made me powerful and my body followed in
three months later my stress fractures
were healed
by running on it also if you want to
have more confidence and self-love check
out my 254 series they're free the links
join on the description below
we are sluggish we're really strong
we're just being sold that we're not
because there's a lot of money it's
about what you're saying to yourself but
it also comes at work so whenever I was
getting beat down physically mentally
spiritually whatever I was going through
just saying you know I would put you
know you can't hurt me successful people
do what they hate to get to where they
want to be rule number four fail your
way to success with Bob Proctor have you
ever thought of failing your way to
success think about that for a moment do
you know that anyone that enjoys any
kind of success feels their way there
that's right they do I want you to think
of this for a moment
see this little light here someone gave
me this as a gift this is a replica of
the light that Edison built and you know
he spent a long time before he got this
thing to glow he really did and
[Music]
he started off because he had an image
of it in his mind that every time he
tried he failed and he failed three
thousand times has been said no I've
never really talked Edison so I don't
know if that's accurate but I have an
idea it is three thousand failures now a
reporter asked him on time how he felt
about failing three thousand times Jesus
I didn't fail three thousand times he's
there were three thousand steps to get
to where I'm going you know if I were to
tell you all the sad stories about has
got me to where I am
I would really spoil your week and
there's been some real sad stories I
think it might even make me cry again
but I've had so many failures that I
wouldn't even want to guess at it I have
I blown everything I had three different
times I never let it bother me much and
you know I have found that every time I
failed I move closer to the goal to see
if you knew how to do it now you'd be
going sideways when you're going after a
goal you're going ahead and because
you're going or you're never being
you're gonna make mistakes you don't
know it all you have perfection within
you and the objective of life is to
bring that perfection to the surface
that's exactly what this guy did well
you're gonna make a lot of mistakes
bringing that to the surface those
mistakes are steps to where you're going
up and tell sales people that are afraid
to make a call just to go out there and
make a call and their objective isn't to
sell their Objectivist just make the
call if you make the call and you're
afraid and you do it you're successful
you've accomplished what you want to do
you made a call and after you get
comfortable making those calls then you
can start to a polish up your
presentation and odds are pretty good
you'll start making sales and if you
keep polishing up your fridge
datian and working they're getting
better you're gonna master a thing
called selling but if you think that
you're going to enjoy great success
there's just one win after another
you're kidding yourself it just doesn't
happen
I don't even know anyone that's pulled
that kind of a deal off if they did they
were cheating or lying rule number five
don't try to be perfect with Marissa
Pierre in my experience people who try
to be perfect are the unhappiest people
in the world and they're almost always
the loneliest too when you try to be
perfect you have entered a race that you
can't win you can't even complete it
there is no finishing line the finishing
line keeps moving so when you're in a
race to be thinner happier richer more
successful you can't complete that race
you can't win it instead of thinking I'm
reaching my goals you feel intense
dissatisfaction here's the truth the way
you feel about everything is down to the
pictures you make in your head and the
words you say to yourself and guess what
is so great you can change those
pictures anytime you can change those
words every thought you think every word
you say becomes a blueprint that your
mind body and psyches everything at
their disposal to make real thoughts are
things what you speak and think and say
without realizing your mind is working
so hard to make that your reality even
if it's super negative you know I see
parents all the time they say things
that I'll be happy when my kids sleep so
they're not I'd be happy with my kids
out of diapers I'll be happy when my kid
is walking feeding themselves going to
school and they spend their whole
child's life looking at the next bit to
be happy when you should be thinking wow
I wish every stage took three times as
long you waste your amazing
life wishing it away for the next bit
because happiness is not a destination
you arrived at it's the journey on it's
an inside job
do not farm out I'll be happy when
because there is no terminal to get to
God happiness happiness is the journey
or on now perfectionist come in all
shapes and sizes and they're often very
good at hiding their inner drive to be
perfect there's one thing that drives
them all and in a belief that says I'm
not enough I'm less than if I'm less
than and I can come across as perfect
I'll be more than you know my neighbors
always say to me wow you have so many
famous clients are they damaged by frame
I'm like no actually no damaged people
are attracted to fame have a belief I'm
so damaged but if I'm famous rich
gorgeous amazing I'll be perfect but you
see what happens when damaged people try
to be perfect it actually damages them
more you don't need to be perfect you
don't need to be flawless you don't need
to be infallible you just need to be
enough and when you lack the fact in
that you are enough to the trying so
hard to be perfect but you can never
achieve when you let in being enough
changes your life so let it in but
you're enough right now that's the truth
about you and rule number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
learn study and grow with Robin Sharma
so few people who could succeed actually
do succeed because they've given up on
learning study and growth LSG learning
study and growth so the neuro biologists
and neuropsychologist will tell us that
the human brain craves learning and it
craves curiosity and it craves novelty
and unfortunately a lot of us we learned
in school but the moment we left school
and walked out into the world we've
given up on our personal commitment to
growth and so I'm I'm inviting you with
great love and respect
to reclaim the curiosity you once knew
as a child when you were overflowing
with awe and wonder you see our natural
state is the way we were as children
we're built to be curious we're built to
be passionate we're a built to be full
of energy
we're built to question things you look
a little child and it's like mommy daddy
why why why why you look at an adult and
they've contracted their curiosity
they've given up on seeing the magic in
the world they no longer grow and so the
mindset I want you to start practicing
because no idea works unless you do the
work to install a core belief you just
practice it until it becomes automatic
that's how you actually get to change
your psychology and so the mindset I
invite you to start practicing each day
is what I call the 2 X 3 X mindset to
double your income and your impact
triple your investment in two core areas
number one your personal mastery and
number two your professional capability
and how do you do that again you do it
through learning study and growth so I
guess what I'm suggesting to you is you
look at most of the population and you
commit yourself to what I call anti
majority behavior if you want to have a
great life a soaring life a creative
life a productive life a ultra
prosperous life look at what most people
do and do the opposite so most people
what they do is they love consuming as
opposed to creating we live in a
civilization of consumers buy this eat
this do this consume this but the top 5%
those who play in the rare air of world
class are not consumers their creators
now I have a special bonus clip with
Gary Vee on how to practice things that
feel scary that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question the one where
do you need to learn study and grow
number two where do you need to stop
trying to be perfect and number three
where do you need to stop discounting
yourself I think for me because I was an
immigrant because I had bad grades my
whole life I was losing that by the time
I was a grown up losing and fear didn't
mean anything to me so I got lucky
in so much adversity as a child I think
if you haven't had that brain if you had
that you still fear it because of the
way your parents judged you know you
have to practice you know it's you know
like you have to practice doing things
that you are scared of it's very true
it's like when people talk to me about
fear it feels so heavy I'm like it's
like swimming or kissing a boy you were
scared of that when you were young until
you did it and then you were we're
talking to me right but then practice
gets you there so you have to practice
things that feel scary and then you'll
get more used to them it's the truth
it's just the truth
if you want to see my take on the
greatest speeches ever check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
I had to use this as the power that now
fuel and we had to flip it on his head
it's a old up this might be exactly what
I need